avec entre autres acteurs michel jonasz
après deux films à moi je j'avoue oui je
suis assez fier d'avoir participé à ce
film parce que c'est un film après
l'avoir vu que l'on garde en soit
longtemps vous savez on voit des images
on se souvient d'une émotion ressentie
je crois que c'est sain bon film c'est
un film s'arrête pas quand là quand la
salle sera d'une vague en garde alors
ceci le 20 mars au en fait dans le film
il s'appelle sylvain kaplan en fait mais
il a sa mère l'a élevé l'a pas fait
circoncire elle a élevé conditionnement
en lui parlant de nouveau rameau ils ont
tué un nouveau raz mieux leurs amants
nouveau n'aura mots nouveaux et il prend
conscience en fait pendant le film c'est
toute l'histoire il prend conscience de
sa judéité il choisit d'avoir le sort
des autres juifs dans le film et il est
déporté par les nazis et sam
votre fils lui aussi c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans le film c'est à dire
que lui aussi vous et sa mère lui avait
jamais vraiment parler de ça c'est
toujours le rameau nouveau et il prend
conscience de sa judéité ils prendront
chance aussi de qui est son père façon
je crois que c'est une question qu'on se
trimballe tous quoi qu'on se pose où au
moins une fois dans sa vie quand on est
juif
ce truc qu'est ce que c'est qu'être juif
que la question est les plus brûlantes à
l'époque de l'occupation pour pour
sylvain évidemment elle est vécue d'une
façon plus beau plus brûlante plus
dramatique tirait mais elle et elle est
la même aujourd'hui pour pour ça mon
fils est la même parce que ses parents
lui dise un moment nous on était deux
enfants cachés pendant la guerre dire
quand pierre grimblat vous a contacté
vous et allez le voir il avait lu cette
scène et vous avez eu beaucoup d'émotion
ce qui est normal
oui et quand je vais relever la tête
vous avez vu grimblat avait les larmes
aux yeux aussi donc évidemment la sphère
et eh oui elle est l affaire était là
vous avez compris tous les deux en même
temps que vous êtes pleuré ensemble
c'est s'armer de queue et c'est aussi le
cinéma qui fait le lien entre ces deux
ces deux destins ces deux hommes mais
surtout pour moi lisa c'est vraiment un
film d'amour où est le vrai lien entre
toutes ces destinées dont vous avez très
bien parlé c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
l'amour alors vous contrairement à nos
héros du film enfin aux deux héros qui
sont silva et sam vous êtes toujours
suivre aux origines on n'a pas essayé de
vous élever dans votre famille
chrétienne man etc
non je vous ai toujours su vous êtes
toujours eu ce sentiment d'appartenir au
bout dit j'ai le sentiment d'appartenir
à un peuple
et vous saviez toujours mais vous dites
aussi ce sentiment peut être dangereux
pourquoi c'est vrai que je me suis
toujours sentie juifs bien sûr j'ai
toujours su mais je n'ai pas été élevé
dans une tradition religieuse enfin le
chat bâtons etc
il y avait passé mais donc maman le
premier contact que j'ai eu avec elle
c'est la douleur ce qu'on me racontait
ce qu'on me disait moi c'était c'est
douloureux des juifs s'étaient les
histoires de déportation de ma famille
et c'est donc je sais si j'ai dit que
c'était dangereux c'est parce que oui
c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'on ne faisait
pas de l'union 47 voyez c'est pas très
loin des grands si ce qui est incroyable
en plus ils gagnent le feu dire lausanne
et qui ne savent pas c'était le centre
de tripes pour expédier voile alors tout
le dans toute l'allemagne c'est fou
d'être né à droite cela il y avait une
peur un peu on le sait bien que cette
génération là qui est venu tout de suite
un peu après la guerre pourquoi il y en
a beaucoup qui n'était pas circoncis il
y avait encore c'est une des raisons 1
on sait jamais oui on peut recommencer
dans le film on l'a vue là c'est un
benjamin que je joue le père du monde
c'est jamais leurs commandes y avait
tellement c'était tellement fort est
tellement intense coise cette peur là
que voilà on ne sait jamais alors vous
vous êtes une famille d'origine juive
hongroise
donc comme je les dîners à drancy votre
père était représentant de commerce
skema loi un fan du personnage que vous
jouez oreille et le dimanche de les
écouter de la musique tzigane cd c'est
marrant ça on allait chez les
grands-parents et puis sortait le tourne
disque là t'es pas appuyé ils sortaient
les vieux disques qui gagnent hongrois
et c'est vrai que ça a été mon mon
premier contact avec la musique pour moi
la musique c'était ça la musique ça
transformait les gens savaient un
pouvoir incroyable quoi ça c'est qu'au
bout d'un moment avec le vin et puis la
musique
en plus c'était quand même des gens qui
avaient quitté des rescapés de la shoah
dont qu'ils avaient ils disaient faut
vivre la vie comme un miracle parce que
c'est vrai qu'il aurait pu leur arriver
le fait d'être toujours là d'être
toujours en vie ça m'a donné une force
extraordinaire c'est donc une intensité
de vie et donc une joie de vivre
donc il ya en même temps une douleur de
ce qu'ils ont vécu ou de ce que leurs
amis ou leur famille ou leurs parents
ont vécu et en même temps une telle joie
de vivre qu'on passe du rire aux larmes
il n'y a pas de banalités on rit on
pleure mais
tout cas on est il ya une joie l'homme
il n'est pas là pour souffrir ou à
régler il ya une joie intérieure comme
sic comme si c'était en attente comme si
elle attendait pour pourvoir
exprimez vous étiez pas à se dévoile
comme vous l'avez dit que j'étais pas
religieuse c'est à dire les lèvera de
pratique religieuse vous la seule chose
qui pour laquelle vous priez à l'époque
c'était pour avoir du bifteck et puis
plus tard faisait mener une espèce de
quête spirituelle
on vit là faisait beaucoup cherché à
l'époque à droite et à gauche
et oui les vues des rabats aux avis des
prés de lui donner j'étais en inde
s'était ramé alors aujourd'hui michel
vous êtes plus proche de l'hindouisme
des philosophies orientales
mais qu'est ce que ce nom d'abord je ne
suis pas je ne suis pas on a vu je me
lèverais une ferrer alors à me suis
intéressé par les circonstances dans
l'air les humains dans les séparent
proche mais non j'adore parce que là
c'est pratiquement le montage on a tous
connu lorient à peu près la même époque
oui et je pense qu'aujourd'hui le les
pays d'europe et d'occident ont beaucoup
à apprendre la philosophie orientale je
sais pas reproche cependant si vous
traitez de vieux baballe non non mais
c'est exact mais ces turbines dossard n
c'est des gens qui vous connaissez ben
oui c'est en émergeant qui ont euros
vilipendé schaller bah oui c'est donner
ces gens qui ont des choses à nous
apporter bien oui à sa beaucoup non mais
je mets profitez-en la non sérieusement
la vie et à la télé oui je dis un truc
là on est à la télé on parle de lise en
a parlé on va reparler d'accord je veux
bien profitez-en alors encore 5 minutes
pour essayer parce que les gens sont
d'accord on est tous perdus dans notre
époque
dites-leur voilà pourquoi vous vous
pensez quelque chose à trouver de ce
côté-là peu près d'accord
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une religion
qu'est ce que c'est que les religions à
quoi ça sert pour moi ce sont des moyens
qui permettent aux hommes des moyens qui
diffère selon les hommes selon les lieux
selon les périodes qui permettent aux
hommes de se mettre en relation avec
leur leur nature divine ça c'est une
question de foi mais ya pas de vérité
là-dedans et à partir du moment où
l'appel où l'état est suffisamment
intense où le besoin est suffisamment
intense pour se mettre en relation avec
cette nature divine intérieur tous les
moyens sont bons c'est pas les moyens
qui courait on s'en fout la belgique
on y va ou est ce qui compte vraiment
c'est est ce qu'il est vraiment intense
ont besoin cet appel à vers quoi faire
quelque chose que tu sans toi qui riche
qui est beau qui alors il ya des
réponses quelquefois avec cette question
qu'on se trimballe mais depuis qu'on est
môme
moi je me trimballe une question depuis
que je suis môme il ya quelque chose
qu'on m'explique pas et quelque chose
d'autre et il ya des réponses qui qui
résonne plus que d'autres alors c'est
vrai quand j'ai rencontré ce que robin
d'eau et mère et sa crème
ça a été une réponse forte parce que il
me parlait pas des choses en isme et de
religion est un achat il disait il ya
une prochaine étape dans notre évolution
et ça c'est une vraie révolution c'est
en théorie ça pour nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est que l'état actuel
de l'homme n'est qu'un des maillons
n'est qu'un des valses et il ya quelque
chose que tout à fait qu'est ce que
c'est qu'est ce que c'est cette autre
étape si nous ne sommes pas le sommet de
l'évolution très sûrement pas mais là
nous sommes des explorateurs quelle
prétention de quoi reconstruire
exactement mission oui quand même un
point bien non mais voilà c'était que
les ratios matériel et donc puisque tu
m'as c'est vrai que la télévision est l
année soit ce sera à dire des choses
avant la lecture de mer est ce que ça
montre bien sûr mais d'être surtout pure
et intense dans son appel et danses ont
besoin voilà on n'est pas obligés de
dire que des conneries à télé bien alors
un jour alors j'en prends votre votre
enfance parce que c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire un jour vous découvrez
complètement par hasard
et ça vous amène là où vous êtes arrivé
après que votre père était chanteur
enfin oui l'été en gris chanteur de
cabaret et que ses parents étaient
chanteur d'opérette n'ont pas n'ont ni
qui avait joué oui d'accord oui c'est
facile ses parents étaient chanteurs
locaux et vous avez un autre grand père
maternel suit la quête et chanteur la
synagogue que je n'ai pas connu voilà
donc en fait vous voulez vous êtes un
jour j'ai découvert que vous veniez
d'une famille de chanteurs simplement
votre père il ait pas eu de les premiers
je n'avais pas oui et c'est votre père
qui un jour à mener dans les années 60
au début des années soixante à l'olympia
vous avez vu
dites bien c'était avait décidé de
devenir artiste à ce moment là non mais
c'était un vrai choc quoi c'était
incroyable cette petite bonne femme
je me souviens de ceux de ce moment là à
quoi s'est elle apprend la première fois
que j'étais dans un musicaux c'est à
l'olympia on avait annoncé le nom
d'edith piaf le rideau était fermée vous
savez à cette époque la lenteur et on
voyait pas les musiciens et après comme
ça puis elle est rentrée tout doucement
elle était déjà un petit peu c'était
tout doucement sous les applaudissements
elle s'est plantée devant le micro cette
petite bonne femme avec sa petite robe
noire et que ses mains comme ça elle a
plaqué ses mains sont contre ces cuisses
et à la chanter et puis sa voix qui
remplissaient cet espace de l'olympia et
puis nous on était là que je me suis dit
waouh c'est quoi ce truc là c'est frais
ça avait une force avait une puissance
la chanson je me suis dit c'est dingue
comme ça peut nous nous bouleverser nous
nous remuer quoi donc
pareil j'ai fait un lien et puis que ce
soit la musique tzigane de mes
grands-parents et puis les larmes qui
venait je me suis dit la musique saint
puissance et quelque chose c'est quelque
chose et voilà alors le vrai déclic
c'est en 62 en fête ses 15 ans et vous
claquer la porte du lycée
ouais vous cassez vous faut dire la
vérité
j'étais pas doué j'étais pas de répit
les autres c'est pas très sympa et vous
parce qu'à l'époque j'étais un petit peu
enrobé 1 et alors on l'appeler jonas la
baleine c'est à cause du bruit dans les
petites classes un pan arrêts après oui
jonas la baleine depuis lors il y en
avait marre il vous dit j'en ai marre
des il faut et à 8 avait un problème
avec le devoir j'ai toujours dit quand
ça va s'arrêter
je supporte plus et là vous partez alors
vous savez pas très bien fait de la
peinture du dessin la comédie exact mais
avec une vraie certitude que vous allez
y arriver si vous n'avez jamais douté de
votre nom car j'aime c'était alors oui
c'est ça est ce qu'on prévoit le futur
où est bien est ce que cette conviction
fait le futur je sais pas mais moi je
crois plutôt qu'on ait eue créateur de
sons de sa vie mais c'est vrai que
j'avais cette conviction l'a tellement
j'avais un oui j'étais pas bien à
l'école quoi ça a été des années
terribles et je me suis dit la liberté
et pour moi c'est vrai que la liberté
s'était d'abord ne pas avoir de comptes
à rendre à quelqu'un ou un matheron et c
est le truc artistique c'était voilà
voilà voyez avant de que la musique
m'emporte qu'elle me presse d
des clins d'oeil que je me laisse
séduire c'est vrai que j'ai commencé par
le drame a commencé avec moi quelqu'un
que je connais je pas qu'il connaît
encore ici vigon oui vigan et les lemon
c'est votre cas moi je connais bah oui
mais bon on s'est connu à baisser assez
connus vigan même c'est un chanteur du
chanteur de rock québécois marocain il
dit toujours il est toujours la décision
en disant ah ben il va toujours non
seulement il toujours en vidéo toujours
au maroc il chante toujours il a un
droit je crois qu'il a un restaurant où
il chantait soir oui oui ils nous
regardent peut-être bruit énorme et a
pas connu ça
et alors après tout peut être le king
cette oreille pu jouer votre copain golf
challenge et après vous finissez quand
même par par chanter tout seul
quel
-
moi
elle la bonne
mais bon
super
on à leur honneur
la même
avec mon père
et quand les variétés
granby
ont passé la journée aux il changeait
tous d'échanger douvres
changez tout
g
en bis
enfants
au delà du sangar et si du bon voire à
carpentier témoins se regardait tout
chez moi ça
m
c'était toucher donc demain projet
fou
est ce que quelque chose a changé
cauchon
miami
oui
dis ça c'est plus attaquées
merci merci
mais les coudes
ça fait plaisir
enfin le dernier ça s'appelle paul ouest
voilà pour l'ouest et le single
s'appelle c'est ça le blues et ça donne
ça
ça me
ka paul lapointe a pas le pouvoir tout
en y aller
vingt jours
et voilà c'est ça le blues michel jonasz
extraits de son dernier cd qui s'appelle
paul ouest 4 alors vous aussi vous êtes
comme julien clerc c'est à dire que vous
faites les dès on n'y a aucune pub pour
un tampon g non vous êtes comme je viens
c'est à dire que vous faites les textes
avant les musiques il a fait beaucoup
d'auteurs compositeurs qui font l'un
vers ce qui commence - jusqu'à l'école
des textes et vous celle inverse
oui pour moi ça me paraît naturel
coincer les mots qui vont faire naître
la musique oui donc je dis que la
musique est là pour exprimer ce que
suggère exactement la façon de
travailler de julien cardy le texte
porte sa rythmique au malin en voilà et
les gens font en général l'averse bien
ébats avec nous